Hello.
Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live. I
am your host, Rawkode.
Before we begin, I wanna take just a
moment to say thank you to Equinix Metal.
They are my employer and they allow me
the time and the resources to put this
the show together and, you know, make sure
that we have quite high quality cloud native
content that we can all learn together with.
If you wanna try out Equinix metal, you
can use the code Rawkode live. This will
give you $50 in credit. You can get
about a hundred hours of compute of our
smallest instance,
or you can, you know, use that money
a little bit less wisely and go for
some of the bigger beefier hardware. It's definitely
much more fun.
If you wanna chat to us, there is
a discord community where you can join and
ask questions or even suggest new episodes and
new technologies that you want to see us
cover.
Please remember to subscribe to the YouTube channel
and thumbs up the video if that helps
other people discover the content too.
And finally, we are gonna be looking at
OpenFaaS,
specifically, FASD today as well as Inlets. And
to do that, I am joined by Alex
Ellis,
the founder of OpenFaaS and Inlets.
Hi, David. How are you? Yeah.
I'm doing very well. Thank you. Yeah. It's
Excellent. Not a bad day, actually. How are
I just found out about the free credits
with Packet.
How
do you get those? I say Equinix metal.
How do you get those?
You can use the code Rawkode live. Let
me let's see. I have this all prepared.
$50
coupon. So you just use Rawkode dash live
as a coupon on metal.does that incidentally,
this has to do with our talk talk
today we're covering. How long would that last
on the cheapest node?
One hundred hours.
One hundred hours. So there's smallest machine 50
in a month, isn't it?
If you think about your Amazon Free Tier,
it'd be about seven fifty hours
for a whole month.
Yeah. I think so. Yeah. So it's about
the seventh of a month you get.
And you could run an Inlets exit server.
Yes. You definitely could. We're gonna take a
look at that today and see. But, yeah,
the 50 credit the $50 of credit allows
you to kinda see what bare metal is
all about, see the you know, it's much
more powerful than running on a virtualization there
and people can just go and play with
that, check it out, and see how they
get on.
Now we're gonna take a look at one
of your projects today. So
should we just take a minute?
We'll cover both of them, what they are,
what problem they're solving, and then we'll we'll
take it from there. So in fact, first,
why don't you tell us a little bit
about yourself, Alex?
Yeah. So
I
I live in England in The UK.
I've been
working with open source technology for quite a
few years, but more recently with containers and
things like that since about 2035.
I've written a lot of blog posts about
containers.
Probably,
if folks have googled for something, they might
have found one of my posts. Or if
you've ever set up a a Raspberry Pi
cluster with Docker and Kubernetes, you might have
come into my materials. So
today, what we're gonna look at
is a couple of projects. One of them
is a bit more niche and a bit
more it started off as an experiment that's
called FASD.
That is where we took OpenFaaS,
a platform for building serverless applications that are
portable, run on containers.
And we shrunk it down
and took all of the clustering out of
it, all of the networking so that the
only thing it does is runs
a single function container
on a single node,
and and that's that. And the reason for
doing it is it just simply makes it
much easier to manage.
Many people don't need an auto scaling multi
node,
multi AZ cluster just to run a few
webhooks or
deploy their first application
or you
might even find that there's a path where
you can start out in the world with
FASD and one VM. When you actually get
popular with your product, you can look at
Kubernetes and start to go go on from
there and upgrade yourself without actually
having to rework your code.
Nice.
So
it's funny that you talk about your blogging.
I I I'm gonna coin a term now.
You know how you get, like, the six
degrees of Kevin Bacon?
I'm I'm pretty sure there's some law here
about one degree of Alex Ellis where every
time I Google for something in the cloud
native landscape, there's always always an article on
your blog. Like, it's consistently
invaluable to me. So I'll just give you
a little bit of credit there. That was
all. Oh, thank you very much.
Obviously, if
one of the things that that I have
done, because you asked about about myself, is
to set out my own.
I've got a company that I founded three
years ago.
I've been working independently for eighteen months now
building up this this company.
A lot of what what I'm doing is
developer
brand consulting,
technical marketing, developer advocacy for brands,
even like Equinix metal. So think about project
that launched and recently be donated to the
CNCF sandbox project before you joined the
team. I was working with the guys very
early on, helping them figure out some of
the teething problems, writing about bare metal
automation and and networking, low level networking, stuff
like that.
So that that part that's a big part
of what I'm doing, but, really, it's this
open source projects like OpenFaaS and Inlets that
that I want to be working on.
And I couldn't find a job that would
pay me to work on these open source
projects.
So I basically created that job,
and
my clients
pay
me for helping them with what I know
best. And then that money, use to fund
my development on open source projects.
Awesome.
Well, we've already had our first comment. A
mutual friend has said hello. So, hey, Alistair.
Nice to see you.
Hi, Alistair.
Alistair is somebody that contributes to both Inlets
and OpenFaaS and a bunch of other projects,
and it's been very active over the last
year.
There are quite a few people that have
contributed to OpenFaaS itself over 300.
Probably
has about 10 or 15 now,
a bit more specialist,
but there are a few people that helped
me with that. Once I had the idea
and proved it out,
they come came on board and really just
pushed it forward. So it'd be kind it'd
be cool to to look at that today.
Yeah.
Just actually quickly looking for a tweet. I'm
pretty sure you posted it the other day
and I was like, how it started or
how we are now? And I was like,
a list of all your You can look
at the pinned tweet of OpenFaaS
OpenFaaS. On Twitter.
Well, let's get that up. Perfect.
Okay.
Let
me drag that there and then pop this
on.
So
That was your DockerCon talk in 2017 and
then, you know, what what are we? Three
years later and look just look at all
those faces. Definitely.
I can see you on that. I can
see Stefan Froden.
I can see Paula Lopez from from Red
Hat. And the funny thing is that I
know a lot of these avatars, and exactly
I can tell you the name of these
people. I can see Johan Siebens. I can
see Phil
from
Research.
There's a whole bunch of faces on there.
Dan, I see Simon.
Nick Nick
is on there as well from HashiCorp. There's
so many faces. Some people sort of came
on
four years ago in 2016 when it was
the first code was uploaded.
I've been around. Some people came in in
the last sort of month,
like, there.
That's something that I that I really like
about the community. Just people attracted to it,
get a sense of belonging and a bigger
purpose than just themselves.
And
recently, we've been converting all of our repos
from
Travis to
GitHub actions. It's been really hard and tedious
work, but there's been about eight different people
that have come alongside
and have really helped with that.
Nice. That's awesome to hear. Alright.
Let's get this closed.
So we've got a couple more comments. Let's
run through those and then you and I
will actually get started on what we plan
to do today. So we have a hello
from Johan. Nice to meet you, Johan.
Hello, Nice to see you again.
More hellos,
Vivek.
And our first question, is this a one
zero one session on OpenFaaS?
Not so much. We're gonna be taking a
look at one way to run OpenFaaS, which
is FASD. And I guess you may learn
a few things about OpenFaaS as we call.
But definitely not the specifics of what we're
gonna enter today. But we'll see how it
goes.
Now my screen's already shared, so I'm just
gonna leave this up. The only thing like,
there's something I always try to do in
a show is never to do anything upfront
or at least to do very little upfront
as possible.
So the only thing I've done is spin
up some bare metal. We have a CT
medium here
on Equinix metal. I have an SSH terminal,
and that is all that I have prepared
up front.
Yep. So that is a way that we
can set up FASD if we start off
with that.
The other way is if you click new
server,
we do maybe we just actually do both
and pick whatever you want, a small one,
whatever's gonna come up quickly.
Yeah. We'll just stick with this this easy
one. I use the OpenTOS
because
I don't generally spend a lot of time
on that for once. And then there's cloud
in it. Can you see where that is?
User data.
Uh-huh. We can drop in some clouds in
it here. Yep. Definitely.
And what you wanna do is if you
go to the inlets
the FaaSD
repo
and
see that cloud config file dot text.
Is this some cloud and a configuration to
spin up FaaS So we do both. Copy
and paste that in and then put your
SSH key in as well.
Okay.
Let's grab that.
We drop this in and we swap out
the SSH key.
Alright. So
s e key. See if I can know
where I had to do this.
Is this an RSA key?
It will be. This is she's in the
secure enclave of the Mac. So the fingerprint
scanner Nice. As my SSH key.
Just grab that.
Okay. So what this is doing is saying
update the package list. It's gonna install run
c. It's gonna pull down container d from
a release. Is what we're using instead of
Docker and instead of Kubernetes.
Alright. In fact, let's look at this on
the GitHub just so it's a bit bigger
for people to see. Yeah.
Then it's gonna restart
system d. It's going to pull down a
c and I plug in.
Yeah. That's right.
And then it clones FaaS d, so it's
building from source? No. It's not building from
source. It's basically, there's some metadata
that defines what services should be deployed,
and it's pulling down the specific
files
that go with that binary release,
then pulls the binary release down. And when
you run FaaS d install
line 22,
that takes whatever's in the current working directory
and overlays it in varlib
FaaS d.
And then the other commands after that simply
just debug information. So if something went wrong
and you look at your cloud and it
logs later, you could see what's gone wrong.
Okay. Perfect.
I love it when I see a sleep
60 in a script.
But this is just installing You won't need
a sleep 60 on bare metal.
Yeah. It is pretty pretty snappy.
Alright. Let's get this run. So we're just
gonna go with that. Now we did have
another
comment from Chris who's saying, does my SSH
key need SSH tars a at the beginning?
It actually doesn't.
This is a different protocol, different cipher. This
is an elliptic curve.
RSA generally, because that's a little bit less
secure these days. So you can swap them
out based on when you generate the key.
And then I left another comment, which I
think is a little reference to you there,
Alex. Mhmm. Will it be a nice arcade
game? Well, we'll looking We might touch arcade
later on when we come to look at
Inlets.
Okay. Cool. Nice. And one final hi from
Emery. Hi, Emery.
Alright. Let's get this spot up so we
can Yeah. So let's deploy that, and we'll
pretty much forget about it and just check
it later to see
what happened. Now on the other terminal that
you had open,
what what we can do and this is
something that Johan is on the call. He
helped with this. He just
took all of those steps and put them
in a batch file. So what we'll do
is clone the fast d repo. I ran
this yesterday on a couple of different machines.
But you don't have git.
Yeah.
K. Get code httpsgithub.com.
OpenFaaS FaaS.
FaaS d.
And that has got a batch script that
we can So if you've c d into
that, and then from there, dot forward slash
hack.
Don't c d.
Stay where you were. And then
dot forward slash hack install.
And
you can fire that away, and we can
we could have a look at it in
the in GitHub while it's going in if
you want.
Yeah. Let's do it.
And it's effectively gonna be very, very similar
to what we saw in the cloud in
it,
except
Containerd doesn't the team upstream team won't build
binaries for ARM, and they won't build them
for for Raspberry Pi either. So I've built
binaries and published them, and this script will
figure out what system you're on and pull
those binaries in.
It does seem to have YUM support, but
I haven't tested that. I'll have to ask
Johan about it.
I don't use Fedora or Chorus or anything
like that.
The CNI plug ins again are pulling off
the correct architecture. So this if you look
at my longer version, was set this variable
export x 64,
set it to this, that, or the other.
So we're just automating it all. Containerd goes
in. CNI goes in.
Run c goes in, and then the fast
d binary, and that's pretty much it.
Okay. So let's
let's try and
break down what fast d is then for
the people that are tuning in today. Right?
They may be familiar with OpenFaaS.
It is a functions as a service platform
that runs in Docker Swarm and Kubernetes
where you can schedule your functions and it
has some sort of eventing for triggering them
and lots of cool stuff like that. Right?
What is different with FASD
to the traditional OpenFaaS?
So for one, there is no docker on
the computer at all,
and there's no Kubernetes. There's no networking
in terms of multi host networking, and there's
no clustering at all. So it's just one
node.
And what that means is that
there's a
there was a
a discussion at the at the software
circus,
not the last one, but the one just
before that. And
Adrian basically
said,
I worry that when people use something like
Knative
that
they're deploying
sort of eight or nine layers of control
plane before they even get to deploy a
single function that might,
you know, be very efficient and very small.
And yet you've got all of this over
overhead. And what I had
I've got it up on my screen, is
I just want to run one function.
Sure. All you need is three to four
VMs,
Kubernetes,
CNI networking driver, a container registry, Ingress NGINX,
a load balancer, cert manager, Helm,
Flux,
CI server,
Docker,
Prometheus,
Grafana,
k native or OpenFaaS,
Istio,
your code,
and then a team to operate it.
Right? And I just want you just wanna
run away at that point. And Adrian's right.
He says I worry about the amount of
control plane there. Not only if you got
Kubernetes,
Istio, potentially Knative for OpenFaaS, and your app,
but everything else that's involved.
All of that infrastructure is actually really expensive
if you think about EKS or even running
on Equinix. It's gonna cost you huge amount
of money.
And so then the cost per invocation
compared to something like Lambda
is ridiculous. Like, it's so much cheaper to
use your million free requests
until it isn't, right, or until you need
a longer run time or until you have
a bigger image or
your team is more used to using containers.
And so, really, FaaS just gets away, gets
rid of all of that,
but it has some constraints that come in.
So you can't have a trade off without
losing something, and what you what you lose
is, well, that can only run on a
single node. You can only have a single
replica of a function,
and it's being orchestrated through system d rather
than
Kubernetes
multi nodes.
Some people are like, well, that means that
you can't have You
can't have failover, but
I don't think that's true.
You can still deploy three FaaS d appliances
and deploy the same function on all of
them and put a l four load balancer
in front of it. Yeah. Exactly.
Single single replicas.
Okay. Well, in OpenFaaS, I might deploy five
replicas of my website.
In FASD, you could just deploy it five
times with five different names
and have a load balance. So it introduces
some interesting constraints.
And what I found quite interesting is that
people are already putting in to production.
There's a company called Sprucey
in China. They do machine learning.
They're deploying their models
in FaaS d like an appliance.
So they build it out using something like
Kubeflow. They push it into a docker image,
and then they just deploy that to FaaS
d, and it's super low maintenance.
As you saw with that script we just
ran In
a very short period of time, you just
have everything working or you cloud in it
or terraform it up and
you're good to go.
Yeah. I mean, I definitely see the appeal
of of this approach, you know. For some
of use cases, like, thinking if I wanna
react to get a web hooks and it's
a really simple thing. I just wanna
write something to influx to be or to
Prometheus or anyone like that for some basic
metrics. Then a fast d setup is gonna
be much more cost effective to me than
running a Kubernetes cluster. Cluster. Now, of course,
if I have a Kubernetes cluster, that that's
fine. Like, you know, go down that path.
Use OpenFaaS.
But there's I can see loads of use
cases for me having a small machine running
all the time with PaaS d and doing
some really cool automation stuff like that. There's
a guy from Puppet that's using it as
well, and he emailed he emailed in and
said, we're using it in our church. Basically,
there's a sermon that's going on live broadcast
a bit like this, but they're they're preaching
instead of talking about technology and tools. And
people can text a number.
You could even use this with your show.
You can text in your question, and it
comes into Slack, and then the staff can
reply on a thread.
And if they reply in the thread, it
texts the person back.
It's completely automated, and it all runs on
FaaS d. He's got the source up on
GitHub. It's in the adopters file for it.
And I just thought that was so such
a creative use.
And I would not want to maintain or
run a Kubernetes cluster just to have that.
No. Definitely not. No. This is definitely I
mean, this runs on a Raspberry Pi as
well. I could have this running in my
house
constantly. But you know that the the treasure
trove, have you accessed that recently?
Last month, perhaps? Did it work for you?
The last time I went on to it,
did work for me. Yes. If you go
to that, that is actually running on my
Raspberry Pi. Oh, is it? Nice. Nice. In
in my house downstairs,
plugged in by the TV.
Exposed via Inlets, I guess? It is firing
less.
Right. Well, I think
let let's show people how that's all works
then. I think let's let's So do do
the do that last command that it's told
you to do there.
Alrighty.
Well, I don't need to sit at all.
I'm I'm
And now we now we basically connected, so
FaaS CLI list
We'll show you what functions are deployed.
There aren't any.
And then you can do, like, FaaS CLI
version, and it'll tell you what provider we're
using. So if you are using Kubernetes or
container that you've forgotten,
you could try that now, FaaS CLI version.
And it's telling you it's using container d
and it's version zero nine eight.
Okay. So by default, when I install and
run FaaS d,
I'm getting a gateway listening on port eighty
eighty for me to receive requests.
You get that. You also get Prometheus.
You also have NATs.
And
if you look at
OpenVim,
for instance, and take a look at var
fuzz d.
Just yeah. Prometheus NATs. Okay. Var fuzz d.
Varlib. Sorry. Fuzz d. Varlib. Correct. Gotcha.
Yep.
So we've got fuzz d and fuzz d
provider. They're two separate processes that run on
the host.
FASD is the basic container orchestrator that starts
all the core services for OpenFaaS.
FASD provider,
its only job is to do CRUD and
invocations on functions.
And we've gotten split out. There are two
different processes that are running.
If you look in FaaS d hosts
is that showing up? Open that one up
if you like.
What we've got here is the CNI plug
in IP addresses for all of the services
that we've started through FASD,
and that then allows us to mount that
host file
into Prometheus, into the key worker, and then
the key worker can say, I wanna talk
to the gateway, and it's able to, and
vice versa.
So it's a basic service discovery.
Okay. And these are all running via container
d as well. Right? These are not native
processes on my host. Correct. Now let's look
at the
Docker Compose file in that re in that
folder.
Now this isn't actually running
with Docker or Docker Compose,
but we were able to use the Compose
format.
This was something that was open sourced very
recently, and there was a nice Golang
library for it. And as I say, many
people have helped with OpenFaaS. Lucas Rose did
the work for this, and
he converted it
from being hard coded in Go because it
started as an experiment as a proof of
concept, and that was fine.
And now not only can you just sort
of go in here and hack on the
variables or update the Docker image from 18
to 20,
You can also add in extra stuff. So
if you want to run caddy and have
a reverse proxy to terminate TLS,
you simply just add it at the end.
If you wanna run influx because you're using
it with your functions or MySQL, you can
add it at the end.
You can add stuff like the Chrome Connect.
In fact, I did that at home just
before
we got on this call on my my
server.
And
this is something that has made it even
more powerful
because you only need this one file. FASD
will will run
and manage the containers for you,
and then FASD provider
runs the the other bits for you.
K. So I can just add stuff to
here?
Yeah.
You need to follow the exact
sort of format that we've got here.
Now what else do you need? Now I
just wanna expose the port.
That's it?
Just check one of the other ones to
make sure that you've done that right. And
you might need do you need a command
on that container, or does it have it
built in? Yeah. It's all built in. All
I just wanna do is run that image
as is. Just look at that example. Stop
scrolling. There you are.
You probably need
net cap raw on it.
I would just copy and paste those two
lines.
Yep.
Looks about right to me.
And then it's because it's in system d,
do a system d daemon reload
and then a restart FaaS d.
Now, again,
one of the benefits of having this in
the journal is that and and why this
is taking a few seconds is it's shutting
down all those containers that are running.
It's not just deleting them or or kill
nining them.
We would do a journal CTL
dash u
FaaS d
and put a dash f on it, and
that would allow us to watch
the logs as they're coming up, and you'll
see various bits getting exposed.
Yep.
The other reason that that took slightly longer
is because we actually had to pull
down
the image for influx.
I would imagine
Unless I got the image name wrong, which
is also very possible. Yeah. Have a look
at the looks.
Okay. Let's do that. Let's do the this
way.
Hit there.
I guess I'll just filter.
You didn't change the right file. Sorry. I'm
changing the get checker. I'm not changing the
one. Just do a c p of that.
C p into the location.
That's that's the
Yeah. There you go.
Yeah. That was that would have been quite
a magic Do every start with an and
at the end and then get the logs
up with an f and then we can
watch it spinning around.
Put it in the background.
So, actually, ampersand.
Yeah. Ampersand. Yeah.
Right.
Dash f.
Alright. So currently,
it's
just shutting down some containers by the looks
of it. Because it's shutting down all the
core containers. So NATs runs, which means you
can actually do asynchronous processing.
One of the things about NAT the NATs
and the way we've used it is that
you can do an invocation. Let's say, I
know you've got your git series project.
You are gonna scan a repo, and you've
gotta check it, not only check it out,
but also
run a bunch of other stuff on it
afterwards.
Yeah. Maybe maybe that isn't correct. Yeah. I'm
just double checking it now. You can have
the function run-in an async way, and then
at the end, it will post the result
of that either to another function or to
a request bin or wherever you want it
to go.
So it's a v
two zero,
and the latest is 2. So let's just
do that.
Alright.
Journal.
There we go. No damage that time. Okay.
So that just means that
there's no added that container to my FaaS
setup yet. It's running. Yeah. So Now here's
something.
Why don't we get the logs for that?
Command?
No.
On the repo,
it would tell you how to get the
logs for a core service.
So that's for a function.
And, also, we have FaaS CLI logs,
and this is for a core component.
And the default there is the namespace. So
probably you're gonna change the the namespace to
OpenFaaS in the future, but for now, it's
just default and then a colon
and then the name as you put it
in compose.
Oh, okay.
Cool.
Yes.
Seems to be running. Now it's
that that's HTTP, isn't it? So what's the
IP address of your machine? Let me see
if I
you read it out to me.
The 147.
Yeah. But let me set up the off
first before someone else does.
Okay. No. That's all I want you to
see. Now
what you might might wanna do is just
actually only expose it on local host instead
of on all adapters.
I'll set this up first and then I'll
do that. Alright. Cool. Done. Okay. Okay.
Now in fact, if you go back if
you just leave it as it is and
go back to that URL again and go
to port ninety ninety.
And this is gonna be our Prometheus.
Now Prometheus is only exposed on loopback.
And if we like, we could just take
it off completely. Now that means if you
want to connect to it, you can do
an SSH tunnel to it and then look
at it from local host, or you could
use Inlets
and bring it back to computer or use
Inlets and expose it somewhere else on the
Internet.
Why is that the case? Well, Prometheus doesn't
tend to have authentication on it.
It's just one of those things that you
probably don't want the world being able to
access.
So this is again part of the power
of having that
declarative file is we can just say how
we want things to look. This instance, we're
just saying
it's only on loopback. So if you go
back to your computer,
you should be able to do curl on
Okay. Curl on local host
ninety ninety.
And there's your Prometheus.
There we go. Yep.
Okay.
So this
is
why I was interested in doing a a
livestream with you because we get to talk
about, specifically talk about, these things. I find
I find them particularly interesting.
Now the other thing we can do is
let's see if I can turn this camera
on and off again.
Is we can put in
It's not happy. Okay. I'll sort my camera
out. The other thing we can do
is we can
there we go.
Deploy something like a cron connector or an
SQS connector or NATS connector
just by editing that file. And then let's
say if it was a cron expression for
five minutes,
you could have it go off and pull
your repo down every five minutes, run a
command on it, and then post the results
somewhere.
But we should probably just start at the
beginning. This is a 64 bit Intel computer.
It doesn't have Docker on it. So if
you want to build a container on your
server, that is normally just a bad idea
anyway.
And if you install k three s, you'll
see that you don't get Docker on there
either,
and so you can't do builds. So you
can still use something like Canico or the
build kit daemon on here, but I would
suggest you build it on your computer using
your local Docker
or on another machine,
push it to registry, and then deploy to
the gateway address of this.
Do you have Docker somewhere?
I do. Yeah. Yeah.
I'll just take thirty seconds. Good. Alright. We'll
have a let's open a terminal on your
client computer.
Know when should be developing on production.
Do you have here?
In
Brew?
It will be in Brew, but it'll be
trailing behind a little bit because they
they take a while to update PRs.
I just get it from
OpenFaaS
on GitHub
slash FaaS CLI.
Okay.
I'll just do it on the visible screen.
So we're gonna go to GitHub.
We're gonna go to open
FaaS
CLI.
FaaS CLI. FaaS CLI.
Typing fail. It's okay.
There we go. And we're just gonna download
the latest release?
Yeah. That's the easiest easiest way to get
it if
unless you wanna actually run the bash installer.
Right. And then copy the link address.
I'll just let it so we're gonna sudo
and beat and launch OpenFinisher.
Fast CLI. Right? Fast CLI.
Exputable.
Okay.
I would normally rename it, but you can
you can use it with that name if
you want.
And this is something you can get from
the installers the installer script.
Oh, where did it go?
It's there. Local.
You just make sure. Membeads.
We go. Okay. So user
Before you do that, do you know the
trick that if you go back and delete
that up to
Darwin?
It's just a little bash trick.
Okay. Now put a
squiggly bracket
like a
the the bracket. Yeah. That one. Then put
dash Darwin
and then a comma and close it.
Try that.
You might have to go into your preferences
just to enable that. You're on Big Sur.
That another go.
Yeah. You can open it this time.
Yeah. I should be able to do it
from here. Okay.
Right. So
all
workloads on OpenFaaS start life as a Docker
container.
You
can just write a Docker file and put
a server in it and put eighty eighty,
deploy that.
But
part of the beauty of using serverless approach
is you just write a handler.
And so if you do fast CLI
template
store list,
you can see a number of different templates
that are available from the community.
Some of them are more official ones.
Because you and I are both familiar with
Go, let's do template store pull,
and then we'll write golang dash middleware.
This is one of my favorite ones.
That's getting it from a Git repo,
and it's brought two down. Fast UI template
list,
I believe it is.
Oh, yeah. I'm sorry.
I'm getting ahead of myself, aren't I?
Yeah. Let's see. So no. New dash dash
list. There we are.
Without the template.
Yeah. And it just shows you what's in
your current directory now. So we could do
a new one with the Golang middleware. This
is effectively just like a HTTP
request and receive a response.
So new dash dash lang
and then Golang middleware.
Yep.
Then we wanna put a name. So we
were talking about webhooks. We just call this
hooks.
And then what's your GitHub what's your Docker
Hub username?
Rawkode.
So put space dash dash prefix,
and you can put Rawkode. All that does
is effectively
creates a new function by taking the top
level bits of it,
put some in place. And if you do
a cat on hooks,
YAML,
you'll see that your username would just got
inserted there. So that saves you a job
by going in and editing it.
Now this file is a stack YAML file.
It can be used to configure build time
and deployment time configuration.
Build time is
what's the template if there is one, where's
the code, what image does it go to,
what build arcs do we want? Do we
want go lang modules on, for instance?
The other thing you then get is run
time. So do we want a number of
secrets?
Do we want environmental variables?
So you have environment variable if you wanna
add debugging or the DB host URL.
This is how I think of it. If
it's confidential,
put it in a secret.
If it's configuration non confidential, put it in
an environment variable.
Okay.
I just pop this open and code, which
is on the wrong screen. And
this is our handler function.
Yes. Under
under the covers in the template folder,
you will see
the original version of this
up on the right.
Yeah. In the function folder. So that's what
the user gets to see,
but there's way more going on. There's a
main dot go. There's a Dockerfile.
There's a go mod,
and this is what you don't have to
see and don't have to deal with. You
don't have to configure a safe shutdown. You
don't have to configure the timeouts. You don't
have to bind TCP ports.
Okay.
So you're
now in on your machine,
and you're doing developer and test. You want
to get this code onto your FASD box.
Just like we did the login before,
you need to log in from here. So
I would suggest you open your Versus code
terminal,
fast CLI login,
and
put the parameters from the other machine in.
Okay.
So FaaS CLI login.
I hear you right?
Still there? Yep.
Sorry. Can you repeat that? I was just
logging in to my I think if you
do dash dash help, it might give us
some parameters.
Yeah. So there's a few examples.
What you could do is you could why
don't you s can you SCP down the
password file so we don't have to put
it on the screen?
Use SFTP
or SCP
to pull it in.
Farlib.
Oh, Farlib.
Okay.
Secrets.
Basic auth password.
Got it. Okay.
Now if you don't get that
okay.
That's okay.
Look at the help command again because it
gives you an example. You can effectively use
cat
as part of the thing. So cat the
password file,
pipe it into FastCLI login.
Okay. FastCLIlogin.
Can you see the command above? So it's
dash s, which is short for password standard
in.
Yep. And then you need your gateway URL
after that.
Gateway.
Okay.
Yep. Let's just grab the IP address one
more time,
and that'll be 8080.
Right? Yes.
Do I need a username? Well, that's in
the file too. No? It's it's
just always admin unless you've offered to change
it, so we just automate that.
Done. Okay.
Now it's saying you should consider setting up
TLS with let's encrypt.
If we had more time, there's a Terraform
that works with DigitalOcean that installs caddy that
then terminates the TLS.
You could migrate that for Equinix metal or
you could just go in afterwards and install
caddy on the host.
So that password's been sent in plain text
over the Internet.
It's just for testing,
but, generally, I would always recommend setting up
a TLS if well, I would say you
must set up TLS if you're gonna do
this sort of thing.
Okay.
Now you can see that gateway dash dash.
We could keep typing that in on every
command. There's always also an environmental variable that
we can use.
OpenFaaS,
I believe it's
you either gateway or URL.
It's gateway, I think. It's a both.
758765.
How can I confirm if it's that? Can
I do a FaaS CLI,
like, kind of what what would what would
go to the gateway and give me some
information back? FaaS CLI version.
Alright. So that's just a c l I.
So let's export that again as you're It's
open fuzz underscore url. Yeah. Is.
That's better. There you go. Great. So we're
connected now.
We're connected to your server,
and we're now ready to do fast c
l I up
and dash f
with the file
that you created. Dot yaml? Yep.
L?
That's the one.
Oh, this is building build kit. Have you
set docker build kit in your environmental variables?
I do have build kit enabled by default.
Yes. Yeah. Okay. Well, that's a cool thing
here because I open fast because it just
literally execs Docker
for the build.
Can make use of that.
So this is building that image with the
code that we just generated from the Golang
middleware template. It's gonna push that image to
the docker registry and then deploy it to
OpenFaaS on a remote server. Is that right?
Yep.
Cool.
There was actually someone who was asking me
about this. I think it was a Akos
or Akos.
He said,
I've got this
API.
It's written in Go. It's running on a
server, single node. I use it for some
stuff,
but I don't know how to deploy to
it.
He said, it's only Docker.
So I can't use Flux. I can't use
this, that, and the other. It's just a
single node running a HTTP API. How do
I update it from the Internet? My GitHub
actions
are building and pushing an image, but I
don't know how to do that last mile.
Well,
you can do this. So if you deploy
FASDs, we've seen you can put influx DB
in your stack. You can put all sorts
in there.
That then gives you a public API that
you can have HTTPS and auth on.
That can be logged into and deployed to
via your PC or via GitHub action. So
that's a good way of then being able
to update code and host these APIs.
K. Now
when we go to this, just take off
that suffix, OpenFaaS f n, because we have
it. We don't have multiple namespaces in FASD
yet.
Yep. Then just browse to this? Yeah.
Hello, world.
Right. So let's just change the text and
then run up again.
The text in the Golang.
Alright. So let's do Harlow
Metal.
I think I've got MODN as well then,
don't we? There we go.
Yeah. And then just run up again? Yeah.
Now
because you're just exacting out
to to Docker here. Like, it's gonna leverage
all my build cache and stuff as well,
which is really nice. Yep.
There's a blog post that I wrote today.
There's a new command called publish.
And what that does, it uses build x
instead of build.
And if you give it a list of
platforms, can build for your Raspberry Pi. It
can build for your ARM server.
In your basement. It can build for your
Raspberry Pis. You can even run that on
a GitHub action or Travis.
You then get a multi arch image. And
when that's deployed,
the cluster,
Kubernetes cluster or FaaS d just knows which
is the actual binary image to pull down
and run for you. You see we have
a little bit of a lag here. Normally,
on Kubernetes,
the operations are all asynchronous.
With FASD, they're synchronous.
So you've got the exact duration until it's
ready.
Yeah.
Easy. Yeah.
And we can make this even faster. You
can if you think about it,
you can cache that build. We could do
a few fewer things there.
We could do the build on a server
that's close to that machine.
Maybe in a few seconds, we could just
have that updated with some new code.
Okay. So
that's FASD.
One thing that you get with containerd
is you get to potentially pause containers.
So you could have a thousand of them
all paused using almost no resources,
and they get unpaused as they're needed. And
the cold stop for a pause container is
ridiculously
fast.
We just go and pause one now back
on the the shell
of the server,
and it's c t r
dash
n for namespace, OpenFaaS f n,
t for tasks,
l s.
Dash t l s? No. No. Just a
normal t or or write the word tasks.
L s. Yeah. Alright. Okay. Got it.
So we got our hooks there. Now you
should just be able to pause it.
Yeah. I'm just guessing, though. But Yeah.
And now do an LS.
So
before we invoke it, let's go to our
OpenFaaS gateway.
You're gonna need to move your terminal down
off off the screen. It's on eighty eighty.
Cap the password, copy it to clipboard. I
think you actually copied it anyway, didn't you?
And we'll paste it into the login dialogue
that comes up, but just don't do that
on the screen. Yeah.
That's not your Mac. Oh, no. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. But we have got the file on
your Mac.
Yeah. Yeah.
So we're just gonna go to this directly
here. Yeah. And then always admin.
And you zoom out a little bit.
Bit more. We'll see the sidebar when you're
ready.
Okay. Click on hooks.
It should say not ready
because
it's paused.
So if you copy that URL
and we put that in a new browser
tab,
that was a cold start.
Nice.
Nice. That was a cold start.
So it is ridiculously
fast
to unpause a container.
And this, you can't really do with with
Kubernetes. It just doesn't have the mechanisms for
it. It's a distributed system. So even if
you unpause the container, it's gonna take, like,
three seconds for all the nodes to figure
out that that happened.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's invoke
this asynchronously.
Okay.
How do we do The
easiest way is probably just to do it
on the command line. We've already got that
URL. So curl space
without the f n yet.
And then just change function to async dash
function.
Yeah. And then we wanna put a message
in because we can take a body and
put dash d
and hello, whatever you wanna put. Hit enter.
Now that hasn't waited to execute because it's
been asynchronous.
My camera's
put on that blink.
What we can do is we can look
at the logs for the queue work. I
remember how we got the logs before.
We did. So that would be general d
dash t
by default,
and then one then the name of my
function,
so hooks.
Yeah. That will give you the the function
for the logs, but what let's get the
functions logs the logs for the queue worker
itself. Queue worker.
I'm just switching over to my webcam while
you're doing that.
Open up pager.
And we can see the indication there and
how it was run.
Yes. We can. And the complete body that
you passed into it
is also there.
Yep.
It's there somewhere.
Now
let's see if we can post that off
somewhere
on the Internet instead.
Okay. You want
So have you you used anything like request
bin recently?
I use Rbox.
Rawkode Yeah.
That sounds like the same sort of thing.
K. So we have an endpoint that can
receive traffic. So are we gonna update our
Go code? Or what's your what's your thoughts
here of what we're doing?
My thoughts are just go ahead
and
set up one of these endpoints on the
Internet.
Alright. As I say, I've used request bin
in the past. What we're gonna do is
invoke the function asynchronously and have it post
back to
your request bin or whatever listener you've set
up.
Okay.
And are we doing that by modifying the
go code or something else? No. You're just
gonna set request bin for me now.
Can you do that?
I have a I have a bin. Great.
Okay.
Now the next part
is to go back to the terminal.
Yep.
And the one that we have on your
machine where you're invoking it. Yep. Just one
more header.
So same again. One more header at the
end
or at the beginning.
X
dash
callback
dash URL
colon
space.
Yep.
There you go. Enter. Oh, okay. So we
can pass in a callback URL for the
asynchronous function, and it's gonna whatever the output
is, it's gonna send it there.
Yep. And if I refresh this, there we
go.
Now, unfortunately, I can't get my camera back
on and I've I've switched over to my
Logitech
stream cam, and it it's not getting picked
up. So we'll just have to leave it
off for now.
Okay. So we got the call. We also
got the duration in seconds of how long
it took.
And you remember how we paused it earlier?
We could pause it again, and then we
could invoke it in the same way. And
the queue work will simply wake it up
to do the work. Or if we're using
a Chrome connector
and this function was getting put into sleep,
we had, I don't know,
for different customers all on the same machine.
We could pause them all or we could
scale them all down even with FASTD. And
then later on,
as they need it, they can just get
scaled up again and as you saw how
fast it was.
Okay. So we're seeing a response time here
of
what is that? Like, nine hundred milliseconds?
I I don't know. Yeah. Maybe. Because Nine
hundred milliseconds.
Well, one thousand milliseconds is a second.
So I think it's Oh, yeah. A faster
than that.
Yeah. Alright. Thousand times faster than a second.
Yeah. Let's pause that again. That's what you're
saying. Millisecond. Just under a millisecond by the
looks of it. Okay.
I'll fix your your judgment rather than me.
That's for sure. So
Yeah. Do it again if you want.
That's paused now.
So
let's hit that again and then refresh this
page.
So it took a little bit longer. Yeah.
But still fast.
Still very, very fast. So we got a
couple of questions there. So first, Alistair said
that was a cool start low. Yeah.
Marcus,
yep, really fast. Nice to see you, Marcus.
No.
S container d using a freezer secret
for the pausing.
I would have to look into that.
It's u it's using
it might be doing that. I can't I
couldn't say for sure. We can find out
later, and we'll we'll get back to find
the code. It's com it's it is open
source, so you can go and look at
it on GitHub later on.
Alright. So
that's
really, really cool. What what what do we
do next then, Alex?
So we talked about Inlets. I think we
should
we should show people Inlets.
Let's do it.
Now
we talked a little bit about the use
cases for this, didn't we, together? And
I think there's a few there's a few
use cases. Right? The first one is
I I'm just developing something on my computer,
and I want someone on the Internet to
be able to access it.
Maybe you've got a local k three s
cluster. Maybe it's just a normal go binary.
The second use case is that you are
a company running
SQL on premises or active directory on premises.
And then in the cloud, you have a
Kubernetes cluster,
and the two need to talk to each
other.
You may think about using a Direct Connect
or a BlackLine.
Come and have
Azure drill a hole through your floor and
put a fiber cable in. Very expensive.
Even setting up a VPN,
I've had customers tell me that it can
cost them a thousand euros a day just
to have someone go and connect to VPN
for a client.
Inlets instead
just runs a HTTPS
tunnel
and then we can put TCP traffic over
it. There's a free version of it that
can do HTTP
traffic.
And so that hybrid cloud use case is
really popular. If you actually go to inlets.dev,
we can
show you a quote from one of the
users.
It's just about halfway down the page
from
to buy us at Fission.
So they they've really
regulated
customers that they work with. The VPC doesn't
allow for incoming connections. They can set
allowed egress.
And so what they do is they run-inlets
in the VPC of customer
right next to the OpenShift API server that
then allows them to build a managed OpenShift
product
and to talk to that API server, list
containers,
and do whatever operations they need to do.
Nice.
Very nice.
So do you want me to download the
binary?
So I was thinking
what could we do? So I sent you
a trial for the Inlets Pro earlier. That's
a bit more interesting. Do you have Kubernetes
running on your on your computer? You say
you use Docker desktop, don't you? Yeah. Docker
for Mac has Kubernetes enabled. Yes.
So if you open the tab that terminal
again, can you show me
kubectl get nodes?
While we do that, I can also say
that null looked at the code and it
does on Linux use the free search secret.
So Cool.
So we don't have Kubernetes.
So Nuno was asking about Arcade.
Arcade
is a tool that
I was trying to think of how to
talk about this. It's basically a marketplace
for Kubernetes.
I think that's probably what we need to
put in the readme file because that's what
it is. It's a marketplace for CLIs.
It's a marketplace for Helm charts.
It's the easiest way we can do the
next step.
So let's say if you go to get
arcade.dev
with a dash,
I did want arcade.dev.
Somebody at at Versa was sitting on it.
If
you're listening, I'd I'd like it.
And, again,
you can download the binary if you like
doing it, the sort of slower way or
the slash.
And, you know, there's a trusting option,
and there's a a less trusting option.
You get to pick what you want.
Well
David and I were friends.
Oh, dear. Oh.
I'll tell you what I did to that
on
we were doing sick sick Fridays in Europe,
and I had about 20 Kubernetes experts watching
me type my Git password in.
It's only a password I use for my
local machine, so I'm not Well, there you
go.
Now
I don't know how to sort this out
for ZSH.
So
okay. Great.
So we got arcade now.
We type in arcade.
Yep.
Yeah. Alright.
What we want to do is Arcade install
inlets dash operator
dash dash help.
The inlets operator is a Kubernetes operator that
runs inlets for us.
Oh, space operator.
Inlets dash.
Yeah. And so if we scroll up a
little bit, we've got various options because
what the operator can do is
it it can set up a server for
you on your favorite cloud,
DigitalOcean,
Azure, whatever it may be.
And then excuse me. We use the public
IP,
and we route the traffic. So any traffic
and bytes that hit that public IP on
that server,
they go into the Inlets server.
It's got a permanent WebSocket established and it
just forwards it onto a client
running inside your cluster.
And then the client knows where that data
goes.
So in the in the example of I
don't know. Let's say we had a load
balancer in an ingress NGINX.
The operator would see that it wants a
load balancer,
creates the host on the Internet.
Then whenever it receives any traffic, it sends
it to the client. The client says, I
send all of data on +1 8443
to
a service,
a service called Ingress Controller,
and then it all just works. And because
you've got TCP for four four three, you
can even use cert manager as well.
I think
we can do this
easier if I send you a tutorial because
I know
you don't you're not as keen on doing
things ahead of time,
but
this is something that we can paste and
chat about. I'll put it on this one.
See if you can get that open.
Yep.
Copy that. There's actually a few people came
to me recently, and they're saying, well, you
know, what to expose a k three s
cluster?
Zoom in a little bit.
Can I use the open source version? And
there's various ways that you can do that,
but the the pro version that we're using
here just makes it so much easier.
There we go. So you need to set
up your access token
for packet for Equinix metal,
and that's the file. That's not the actual
value.
So have you got a a file on
your disk with
an API key in it?
I can get one.
Let's do that. So over on your dashboard
under
your account,
sure you know where to get it.
Yeah. I've done that once or twice.
Alright. Let's see. There is a code there.
So let me just pop open one more
terminal.
Open window, please.
Here.
Secrets.
So
them dot access.
Now each provider on the Internet could take
different options. Packet,
the packet providers, it's still called that, It's
relatively
straightforward.
The only extra thing we need above
in this command is the the project ID.
Yeah.
The region can be left blank
and it would default.
What can I ask a question quickly? See
the license fail, is that the entire thing
you sent me or just the key?
It's just the job at the end. Alright.
Got it. Okay. Let me get that. Alright.
Okay. So we got
oh, and let's
put that in it.
Alright. So I've got two files.
So I need to export
this.
Computer. Yeah. Okay.
And this is going to be
what's last dot
oh, I zoomed in. That's what it was.
Got it. Is it in that temporary directory?
Is that where you have it? Yeah. I've
got it here. So Okay. Access
and my license file is
very similar.
It about slash and
Just do an l s if you can.
Access button that's Yeah. Looks good. Okay. So
now we can run this command here.
I would not run that because it's
wrong for you. Maybe put it in a
text file. We'll edit it and then
run it.
Yeah.
So we're gonna run with the packet provider
Yep. AM six.
I would get rid of the region because
I
it will default to Europe
anyway.
Yep.
Token files, correct. License file, correct. The other
thing you're gonna need is your project ID.
That is project ID, like And that isn't
confidential.
So you I don't know. Should just be
able to paste that on.
Well, I mean, I've already flashed my, you
know, machine's password. What's a few more things?
At least you have the secure
enclave for your SSH key.
Okay.
So let's
I don't know if that needs quoting. We'll
find out.
What's happening there?
Well, it's downloading Helm Helm three
because
it's just easier
if it's one command rather than telling you
download Helm at this repo, update it, now
apply the CRD. All of that's done for
you,
and it's done in a temporary directory so
it doesn't interfere
with your stuff.
Have you got any services in the cluster?
If you get kubectl get service dash capital
a,
what have you got? There there won't be
anything.
Let's see.
No. You don't have anything. You want me
to deploy something?
We wanna deploy something that has a load
balancer on it.
You mean a service or an actual load
balancer? About
a load balancer service. How about we install
Ingress NGINX?
Okay. Can we do that with Arcade? We
can. Alright. Show me the magic.
Arcade install
Ingress
NGINX, and we don't need any parameters for
this one.
Someone asked
me, well, what about if I want to
go actually, we've got the tutorial. I don't
know why I'm talking you through this. We
should go back to the tutorial.
There we are. So
install nginx,
install cert manager.
Get that one ready.
I don't know if Martha's gonna be watching
this later.
Okay. So let's go over this review. I
have installed an nginx ingress.
We got the endless operator,
and we got cert manager. So does that
means I mean, in theory here, I can
expose
that NGINX
Ingress
to you.
You It's already getting exposed right now. Have
a look on your packet dashboard. Let's see
if we've got the server getting created.
Is this the right project ID? Do you
need to refresh?
I'm
pretty sure that's the right project ID, ED10.
Interesting. Okay.
Let's do arcade info inlets operator.
Arcade info
inlets.
I
might have told you wrong earlier about the
region, and then let's get the logs of
the operator to see if there's anything
going wrong with it. The thing about Arcade
is anything
that you install,
you also get a help message that you
can pull back at any time, whether that's
OpenFaaS or otherwise.
Yeah. It's just in Lan 1 London 1
by default, which isn't a.
No. So we just need to do an
install again, same command.
And then at the end, just put region.
And I don't think it's with a space.
Yeah. Is it a m six?
Yeah. I use a m six pretty pretty
insclusively. The code is okay.
Well, we should see something spin up here.
Right? Yeah. We should do. And let's get
the logs of the operator again. Just have
a watch of that.
No. You don't have any a any t
one smalls there. I use use one smalls
for them. T one smalls are mostly deprecated.
Can we overwrite the
machine It's hard coded.
We use the cheapest one that we could
find. I'm actually surprised.
Let me see what region I was using
then
because this is the first one that I
added to it.
It should be in OpenFaaS only Inlets docs
as well.
Let's see if I can find a t
one small then.
Yeah. A m's one has it, which is
a Yeah. That's one I use. A m
s one.
That's the older data centers. Oh, cool. Requests
are welcome.
Okay. On that, don't you worry? Okay. So
now that we're using a data center that
has a t one small available, we should
see our server. There we go. Yeah. There
it is. And it's got the name of
the service it's been exposed for. We've got
the IP.
We're using
an older version of it been to because
packet I don't know if it's still the
case, but it used to have, like, accelerations
for certain images.
They were precached on the hosts.
Okay.
I don't know. And 16 o four was
what what's the image?
The guy the other guys will will know
Jacob or Ed.
So
Yeah. That's a that should be fast. It
should be under a minute roughly for that.
Yeah.
Now on other clouds,
like DigitalOcean,
you're not looking at bare metal. You're looking
at literally just
AVM running with QMU.
That's lightning fast. So you'll get one of
these in ten, twenty seconds.
Now if you aren't used to the speed
of Amazon or something like that, you know,
you can be waiting ten minutes, I often
am.
It's
normally a lot faster than that.
We got our IP anyway.
And what's gonna happen once this starts up
is it's just gonna run Cloudinit on the
host.
It's going to pull down the Inlets Pro
binary. It's gonna install a system to unit
file, start the service,
configure it with the auth token that was
generated by the operator,
and it will be listening
for requests.
Inside your cluster, you should see a pod
in the default namespace called something like tunnel.
Maybe it's a deployment in case the pod
isn't starting yet.
Interesting.
What about other namespaces?
I don't see a tunnel.
No. I don't see it.
So you should have a client get scheduled.
Let's look at the logs again of the
operator just as that host is coming up.
Anything further up? Yeah. It says it's syncing
the default Ingress NGINX controller tunnel. Yeah. That's
that should be the deployment. Yeah. What else
have we got in the logs?
A great deal. Okay.
So
There we go. We got it Yeah.
You can look at the logs of that
if you want.
You see it's connected now. Ports 18443
are getting forwarded.
Now I'm gonna try it from my computer.
1477584223.
Yeah.
And it's giving me
exactly what I would expect to see
from
NGINX if I'd exposed it from an ALB
on Amazon.
Can you click on what I sent you?
Yep.
So not found because we haven't got any
ingress records yet.
We're not looking at a domain.
The next thing in the tutorial
will allow you and we could have a
browse of it, decide if we wanna actually
do it now or not.
We'll allow you to
deploy an application,
define an ingress for it, use set managers
ingress shim, so you just put at the
top this needs certificate.
And then it gets you a TLS certificate
that just works.
And
if you click it getting production certificate,
it should show you what that looks like.
So you just simply create production issue instead.
You would then go down
a little further,
a bit more,
and you end up just getting something that
works like that.
Nice. So you're only a couple of steps
away from that, really. The only things you
need to do is the IP address that
we had in the browser that said not
found. That's the IP that you would associate
with your domain.
So it might be rawcode.com
or
Alex's example dot raw code dot com. Create
your c c name or your a record
for it.
Deploy the issuer.
Create an ingress,
and cert manager will get a TLS certificate,
terminate that inside your Docker desktop,
and cert will be stored on your computer.
So if you shut the lid on your
laptop and went to Costa's, opened it again
or Starbucks,
you wouldn't have to do anything, And it
would work exactly the same as it is
now. Just reconnect, and it will it will
go around with you.
Ah, that's pretty cool. I do like that.
The
things that I like to do with it,
you see under underneath that real world application
is these are the commands
to get OpenFaaS,
for instance.
So you don't have to create an issuer.
You don't have to create an ingress because
that one command just does everything.
So empty cluster,
we do the three commands we did earlier,
then those two, and suddenly you have OpenFaaS
with TLS.
Or as it's quite popular at the moment,
there's a lot of talk of Docker registries.
If you look a little bit lower down,
again,
two commands and you get a docker registry
for yourself with auth on it and TLS.
Very cool. I like that.
Quite a lot of flexibility,
quite a lot of power
mixing all of the all of these tools
that you're working on together, you know, using
Arcade and OpenFaaS
and Endless. This seems to be
solving a lot of common developer frustrations and
challenges,
which I like. Yeah. I mean, I'm reading
this book
called Start With Why. Have you read that?
I have by Simon Sinek. Yeah. By Simon
Sinek. And whilst
I haven't got very far into the book,
just that one premise of starting with why
got me thinking, and I wrote down. I've
got my journal in front of me here.
Why did I create
each project?
And is it still something that I want
to contribute to and work on, or is
this something that
is surplus to requirements?
And, really,
the the one example there for the registry,
as I said, I was doing consulting for
clients writing technical blog posts. Sivo
wanted to build a bit of technical chops,
a bit of sort of credibility with k
three s, and I wrote them a tutorial,
installing a Docker registry
with a TLS certificate and authentication.
And it was literally 5,000
words.
And today,
because Arcade exists,
it's those two commands plus the command for
Ingress Engine X and the one that we
did for cert manager. So four commands.
Nice.
And it would be the same for anything
else. So I don't know. Let's say New
Relic or Sysdig had an agent that they
wanted to get a bit more traction for.
First of all, you generally need to have
all these base things in place to make
the cluster usable anyway.
If you're then gonna go and install, you
know, like an agent or something at the
end of that, why not have everything all
in one place? Super easy.
And then when it comes to production
and you're saying, right. I'm gonna
I'm gonna use GitOps, one thing and another,
you're probably not gonna sit there running arcade.
You're probably gonna
take your time and mirror the repositories,
mirror the charts,
set everything up with GitOps, and and, you
know, spend weeks and weeks on it.
But this is something that can really accelerate
adoption.
The time to actually taste and see what
something is like
is so much faster when you have something
like this.
Yeah. Definitely. I can see that.
Now I I realized that we're kind of
approaching the end of the time we had
scheduled for this. So, you know, is there
anything that you wanna show off before we
we we wrap up for today? I just
wanted to see what questions people might have
about what we've looked at so far.
Yeah. If you're watching and you have any
questions you'd like us to tackle in the
next few minutes, please drop them into the
chat, and we'll do our best to get
them answered.
So what else like like,
Arcade is is open source as well. Right?
It's on GitHub. Yeah.
Based on what I see when I installed
the n NGINX ingress operator there, it's wrapping
the helm charts and providing sensible defaults. Is
that how it's working? Yeah. It is.
So
but but here's where it gets
trickier as a as a developer.
Kubernetes dashboard,
it's not a helm chart for that. It's
just a manifest.
Breaks a lot. The version changes.
You then have to create a token for
it and
run a proxy, and it'll always get it
wrong.
So we created an arcade app for it.
It's now one command, and those gnarly commands
you can never remember find
arcade info
Kubernetes dashboard.
And that's completely gone away, that problem and
that that friction.
For Linkerd,
there's about six commands that you need to
run. You download their CLI, then you run
six commands, then you get Linkerd. We've
just made it Arcade install Linkerd.
Yep.
It downloads the CLI for you. It makes
sure that it's a suitable version. There are
a couple of overrides that you can pass
in.
And then, yes, rightly so, OpenFaaS is a
helm chart.
Mongo is a Helm chart. Istio is currently
a Helm chart. The Inlets operator is currently
a Helm chart. But with Arcade,
the the glow the glorious
thing is is you can hide all of
that.
So whatever is available upstream, the developer doesn't
have to care about it. Just
one command and they've got it.
And can people submit new packages to that
just by I mean, is it relatively trivial
but people to get involved and add other
applications to Arcade?
Oh,
Alistair,
if you're still listening, I know we've got
a few of the contributors on there. What
do you think
you can put a comment into the chat?
Yeah. We'll just need to get some a
little bit of time. I think there's roughly
around lag. Thirty second lag. Whilst
you're doing that,
I'm just taking a look. There's 32 contributors
so far
to this project.
So
that probably goes some way to answering the
question.
Yeah. And one of the things that we've
done more recently is just to
to make the code, like, a little bit
more expressive like an API.
I'm just gonna dig one out and point
you at it actually. Yeah. Go for it.
Because
I guess the OpenFaaS one is a nice
one.
That's a bit more for both.
Yeah. The sealed secrets one. So if you
have a look at this,
it's like a fluent API.
That's how you would install
sealed secrets.
And then for overrides that you wanna pass
in, I don't think this one actually has
any, but you can use dash dash set
or we have aliases.
So it might be like dash dash load
balancer if you're changing the service type or
dash dash authentication
mode.
Those kinds of things are typically hard to
discover in the chart, readme file,
and now bubbled up as flags
just like you saw when you did Inlets
operator dash dash help. Yeah. It showed you
the different providers and the names of them.
Okay.
Yeah. That doesn't look too difficult at all
to try, you know, to to get involved
and
and add. And I'm assuming if I just
click on apps here, I'm gonna get a
list of
Yeah. All the apps supported by our There's
about 40 now.
And then there's the CLIs.
So
if you think about it, when you start
a tutorial, if you've got no Kubernetes knowledge,
you've gotta get kubectl,
get kind,
maybe get fast CLI. All of those are
now behind
arcade get.
So you get arcade get kubectl.
You can even pass in a version to
that.
And I I think you want quite a
cutting edge version on yours. But if you
wanted to test one seventeen
or you wanted to test the new patch
of one nineteen, you can just put dash
dash version, and it will pull down the
binary for you.
And compared to updating Broom waiting for it,
it's super fast.
Alright. Cool.
Well, I think that gives people a good
idea of having involved in ARC it too.
So
Yeah.
So let's just
open one more thing.
This is how people can get in touch.
If they
go to openfaz.com/blog,
We have a whole bunch of tutorials, always
looking for people to write them and contribute.
This is where you get a lot of
news, a lot of new features.
There's a new post that came out today.
You've also got the store there and the
new Christmas jumper.
Just a bit of fun.
If you're interested in getting anything, it helps
support the project, and you can wear it
on Zoom. And then the other link is
the community
link in the docs.
And if you go there,
you can join our Slack, and that's where
conversation happens for catch up and arcade, and
and there's an Inlets channel as well.
Sweet. Perfect.
Nice.
Alright. Well, I don't think we're gonna get
any comments.
So I think with that, I'll just say
thank you very much for joining me today.
It was really nice and great to take
a look at
Well, we looked at a lot, didn't we?
So we've got FASD and Inlets and then
we even brought in a little bit of
Arcade as well. So thank you for your
time today. Thank you for your continued work
on these awesome open source projects as well.
And I hope you have a great day,
Alex. Thanks.
Alright.
Thank you for watching. I'll speak to you
all soon. Until next time. Bye bye.